[Music]
first of all congratulations I have just
the fight scenes are so I I'm in love
with you now and I'm a repressed
Catholic seeing a woman beat a guy it's
just it's fantastic it is so much to
talk about first of all how did you you
started out as a mixed martial artist
and you know you said such a beautiful
woman I'm just curious how you got
interested in mixed martial arts in the
first place um well I was drinking for
days with my ex-boyfriend one night and
no I don't need to hear anymore
anything makes sense after that yeah and
he wanted to kind of change his life and
so he woke up the next day and went to a
gym and started training and then when I
went in and watched him like the good
girl when I was mm-hmm and then I
started you know fighting five months
later so you're watching it starts off
with your boyfriend oh don't be nervous
I've - what you can do I've seen what
you can do ah
and worry about it's just me you can if
at any point you don't like the way the
interview is going you can just take me
out and then turn on and ii know i i'm
curious because you so you're watching
your boyfriend do it and then you
thought i'm gonna give this a try well
yeah i walked into the gym and i this
tie guy this little time and was like oh
baby you fat you need to lose weight and
i was glad you were fat yeah well I was
chubby yeah I mean I really need to get
back into shape right and so I started
you know training with him actually the
same guy that called me fat and and then
I find those later I find myself in a
gym in San Francisco and it's like like
it's kind of like Fight Club you show up
and you fight whoever's there and
there's like no heater or there's no air
on there's sooner people in the gym and
it was like the the ring is down in the
corner and I was fighting this chick and
it was like and you just knew this is
the right thing for me I'm good at this
feels good yeah you know it's funny
you've done your fighting in a cage
you've said this is a court of yours you
likened cage fighting to sex yes you did
I want to know why that's true in great
detail well there's a cage yeah
Andy we're not talking about your kinky
yeah you think about it it's a very real
interaction between two human beings and
it's them it's like an energy like you
have an energy and I have an energy and
it's you know like an energy that nobody
else is gonna share yes so did they tell
you I was a perv here I'm actually a
huge fan of yours oh thank you I'm
seeing you with my 40s forever all my
fans are drunk so I see what's an
intense human connection that happened
so I could I could see that do you ever
find that your your partner when you're
fighting tires more quickly than you do
are we talking about men or women right
now we're talking about sex or fighting
I don't care I really don't care it's
all so amazing to me